all right it looks like we're live
hey everybody who uh has decided to join
this evening i hope you're well
it's great to see you thank you so much
for joining me this evening
for an empathy wines tasting the new
vintage i'm gonna have my uh partners
nate and john here i've got a
surprise guest that i'm excited about
and i know a lot of you have picked up
the wine to try
and taste along with us so i'm really
excited please say what's up in the chat
uh so i can see some of you matthew
carroll good to see you from australia
um good to see you all of you this
evening hope everybody's well
danish cindy would be raphael peterson
good to see you
canna walgreen uh dustin maybe we can
get somebody on team gary
if you can text the thread to go live on
instagram
and um just stick it to the front of the
camera
jonathan bell mina good to see you scott
luke what's good
great to see everybody from linkedin and
facebook coming on
dustin did you see that come on film and
tell me if you did
what you just said yeah to get somebody
on the team go live on
instagram and just hold the camera in
front of the computer yep
you put that in the thread doing it
right now awesome it's good to see you
oh me too
i know a lot of these people miss you
from tea with garyvee we gotta get that
going again
yeah yeah
see ya okay um james great to see you
remember good to see you michael n
papa punk is in the building rodrigo
great to see you from brazil
uh so we're gonna taste these three
wines kind of new releases from empathy
we're gonna talk to john and nate my
partners in crime see how they're doing
since the acquisition
then we've got a little bit of a special
offer for everybody who wants to
be part of uh the wine club
um and uh and i miss all of you and i
hope everyone's super well
and uh let's uh let's bring on my
partners in crime
uh dustin maybe as i'm pouring this jose
you can bring on john and nate
and they can say hello
hello john and nate what's going on gary
how are you
good anything interesting
uh just poured a little white myself mr
troutman you're a mew
classic one year later and i'm still
doing it
one year later and you're on mute is
still overworked
uh real quick in the chat while we're
about to say hello
would love to get a sense if you have
bought empathy wines please just put
yes or no as a reply right now big shout
out to josh
allen hey shell just trying to get a
sense yes or no please
um so john nate obviously we
sold empathy uh in i guess officially
what
march of 20 june thank you okay
i negotiated my part in march uh june uh
why don't you give everybody since a lot
of people here know who you guys are uh
by the way a lot of no's here we have to
change that dustin throw up the url
um we have our subscriptions on discount
i create a nice little url here
it would mean the world to me as the
majority of these are known
john and nate you might be in trouble
here way too many knows
some not yet uh there is the
urlgaryvee.com
ewing status for empathy wines if uh
some of you in the comments section
could do me a huge favor
and link this url so it's just clickable
for all the people in the chat
um we're really excited about empathy
and this year and for this event tonight
we've created this discount
uh on the 3 6 and 12 packs that
i hope you can get excited about because
we're pretty damn excited about it
um but john nate why don't you give a
little story time on how things are
going in
your new hole you kicking us off
yeah sure yeah it's been it's been an
awesome i guess eight months
now at constellation um it's very
different going from
entrepreneur and co-founder into a
company like constellation
um but also you know has tons of upsides
there was fires in the valley this year
which were devastating
um but having a support team and
infrastructure like constellation behind
us
allowed us to create the wine that we
wanted to create going forward
um so much more resources at your
disposal
to to really build a business and build
a company that
that we're continue to be proud of so
definitely very different
um learning a lot but excited about the
next vintage for sure
john um yeah i think just building on
what nate said our day-to-day
has changed a ton right you go from john
excuse me real quick um
carl carl m just said gary will you
marry me and i'm going to say yes to
carl big day here
so for everybody celebrating carl and
mai's marriage please go to garyvee.com
ewine and order a 12 bottle subscription
which by the way the subscription gets
you the red wine first
right man yup so we're shipping the red
wine right now
and then the rose will come in a couple
months our new rose which is our 2020
rose will come
probably mid april and then our 2020
white will come
early summer um so right now we're
shipping the 20
2019 red um and then the 2020 red will
be will be next year
john did we just get you and carl a
wedding registry drift gift i think you
think that's good we did but i just want
to make sure you uh
you get to say what you need to say um
yeah i was gonna say like
our day-to-day has changed a ton but
when it comes to the actual like making
of the line i think the really nice
thing is like
not much has changed at all like our
mission remains the same
um like they've given us the autonomy to
continue
um uh working with the people that we
want to work with source the type of
wine that we want to
uh source from the top type of growers
that we want to work with so
from that standpoint the mission remains
the same to deliver like the best price
wine that we can for for the money um
our mission for like the best 20 brand
and now with the discount it goes lower
with
when people go to garyvee.com
has really worked for us um for people
in the comments a lot of knows
when a lot of people share in the url so
thank you i'd love to see some people
sign up for some subscriptions
um nate are you able to see the
subscription orders come in
yeah yeah it's very important to me that
we give full name shout outs to people
as orders come in right now um we do not
ship to the uk right guys it's america
at this point
yep u.s
not every state because the laws are
tricky but um
uh i definitely want to give shout outs
nate to people that order
specifically people that are um you know
one case things and then
i also have a special guest that we'll
have in a couple minutes which i'm
excited about
um but most of all
i'm extremely passionate about getting
some wine information
and some entrepreneur information on
this evening because i know we have a
lot of people here so
wine information john nate and
especially john because i think you're a
better wine guy than nate
you know what what's going on in the
wine world from your perspective from
your palate from things that you're
excited about things that you've tried
so i feel like uh california has been
like absolutely crushed the last few
years with like vintage issues but at
the same time
i think the wines are better than ever
like wine making has just improved so
much even just in the last like 10 years
do you think wines are more balanced
john i think they're more balanced i
think they got a little crazy there for
a while where they were like so over the
top
and finally now it's getting back to
swinging the pendulum
um to a good place um nate you're
prepared to give people shout outs on
the screen right
as soon as i see him understood go ahead
john
um i think like the uh but just like the
sheer quality like
you see the just massive consistency
where every single year now even amid
the wildfires
like you're able to source really really
good grapes and make really really high
quality wine
um which that it's gotten that much
better i think even just in the last
like 10 years
um and then in general like i think rose
is
is obviously a massive trend um and now
getting like a first-hand look at
constellation with the deep like
research and insights they provide like
it's not going away like it's just it's
just maintained it's like a category
unto itself now it's almost like people
think of it as not wine
um where people just view it as like in
the way they view sparkling seltzer
beer wine it's almost like rose is a
thing unto itself
so that's super exciting in my mind uh
dustin we can we can have as many people
as we want on screen right now
i can have a big shout out to chaz
torchett oh obviously yeah so we're
gonna bring our guest in one second
i also think that i want to incentivize
one case
let me just see this url so garyvee you
go there you scroll down the connoisseur
three shipments 12 bottle each 204
discounted so nate i assume that's 600
bucks to get
you know a case of red white and rose
for the next year
of empathy 6 12. um
may's asking if you could shout out
instagram because they think it's
pre-recorded
so instagram what's good this is super
live um it is 6 40 p.m on monday
february 15th
uh i don't know what else i could do to
prove it uh there we go
here's my phone actually let's see well
i guess
on my instagram she's logged into my
account
yeah instagram is real um okay there you
go
dustin let's bring in our guest because
i'm extremely fond of him and i think we
need him here
hey hey hey josh how are you dude i'm
great i've got a ton of food here i hope
you guys are
ready for it too bad you can't taste it
yeah i'll watch you eat it and we'll get
jealous but real quick
please tell everybody who you are and a
little bit about yourself because i
really wanted to
give a little flex to you and your
incredible career
for sure yeah uh well i'm thank you gary
i appreciate you having me on here uh
i'm josh weissman
uh i run a youtube channel under my name
i've been cooking my whole life i have a
long background
chef background i cooked in some of the
best fine dining restaurants in the
south central region of america
i would have been the youngest sous chef
at that restaurant until
i ended up going full time on my own uh
brand and career on
on youtube and social media and
everything like that and now i produce
tons of videos for
uh my youtube base now 3.5 or what am i
at i don't even know where i'm at
anymore 3.6 million
subs and uh growing man growing loving
it
what made you jump into influencer life
and what kind of chef do you consider
yourself so give me those two answers
well i mean i it's kind of a it's a
difficult
word to place right because to me a true
chef is somebody that's at the helm of a
restaurant
and i don't have a restaurant yet it's
coming
it is coming uh but until then i don't
feel right about giving myself that full
title
um so i guess i'm a chef in training if
anything until that happens but
um beforehand i was a lead cook at a
fine hang restaurant now i think
i don't really consider myself as much
of a social media influencer because i
have i'm gunning for so many different
things at once
um but for me it's more about excuse me
for one second nate do we still ship to
south dakota because chris jacobson
north dakota's in play
chris you're in play go ahead josh
josh you don't consider yourself an
influencer you don't consider yourself a
chef
the hell do you consider yourself a man
with good hair
yes 100 that's it no you you you hit the
nail on the head that is exactly what i
i wield knives and i have great hair
that's pretty much all i do at this
point that's your life
yeah exactly where is your cooking
journey
oh i'm like very very far behind josh
i'm like
just a hobbyist at home are you decent
i'm pretty good like i got no essentials
down i can roast a chicken
i might be the worst cook on this on
this ice cream
that's true that's true why i want to
know why
yeah why nate um you lack effort i lack
effort
i haven't given up that commitment i
feel like i have it inside me
but i just haven't given it the uh the
effort needed to
to exceed i feel like i could be one of
the great chefs of all time
if i applied myself
head-to-head as soon as as soon as we
can get together we're going
head-to-head it's happening
i love it i love we're gonna have a
cook-off all right josh let's taste this
rose
together yeah you have the uh 19 rose i
have the 19 rose
nate john maybe you guys can talk a
little bit about the 20 rose
which will be the rose if people order
now and they maybe on the garyvee.com
ewine
can you explain the three six and twelve
subscription thing
and since nobody's offered yet i since
nobody's bought on it yet you've not
been able to tell us
oh you've got some sales yeah so we
gotta give some chat nate this is like
that
i wanna give people some real flex and
some love i'm very grateful for these
sales
let me just refresh because we got
another one all right wait where's the
puns you're very grateful
sorry all right i'll just stop there
yeah that'll be the only
one you're not a chef you're not an
influencer you're a comedian
yeah yeah like i don't even know if i
could say this like a
a douche level comedian that just kind
of stops right around there
good news you can say anything here okay
there's some love first
yeah we got uh tyler whitlow
uh jongus ed bruce stageberg christine
scotto that's such a great name uh lisa
shell
edward santana brian walsh mike
silvestri and a couple more coming in
gotta refresh again
josh are you doing any clubhouse rooms
okay
i know you're gonna ask me this [ __ ] um
so i just got on clubhouse and i'm still
figuring it out but i haven't done it
yet i'm going to
okay i need to find the right person to
jive with you know and i mean i need
somebody that i can
drive i'm dude i'm you know i'm here for
it you know i'm here for i went in one
room and it got really awkward and i
just dipped real hard
john troutman nate clubhouse
i'm uh i listen in i tune in mostly on
the sports cards chats
the last one i was in was some frat
house guy
roast where it was just a bunch of frat
house guys shooting their shots
at girls in clubhouse was this
was this the whole silicon valley nyu
yes yes i was literally saw that
headline which was fascinating but i'm
like i'm not going in there
like i couldn't help myself because one
of my friends was in there it was
my friend codyco was in there and he
actually got like brought in as an
advocate and it was really
it was really funny and just insanely
awkward
by the way nate bruce has been a long
time wine library fan which is why i
gave him the name shout out
i'm super aware of that name for a long
time any other new names nate
well john comes in and talks about his
clubhouse um
tyler honga and james phillips who's
bought a case subscription any money
because i want to give them two case
subscriptions christine scotto and lisa
shell
hey dustin are you able to give the url
that we're on
to the two people that just bought a
case so i can answer a question for them
so i could show them supreme love like
anybody who orders like a case
are you able to have like zayn right now
watch maybe
give them the url and then you'll see
them backstage look i feel like i want
to get like i'm very prices right i'm
very like let's make a deal a very like
you know me dustin i'm very spontaneous
i could
i could send the uh url to nate and nate
can
text it to them oh yeah exactly he
emailed it to them that's exactly right
give nate the url email that's an eight
that's it doesn't come back why'd you
leave i love when you're on screen
sorry url nate
so wait nate gets the url nate sees a 12
bottle
subscription come in the 600 one he then
emails those people that they come in
will they be in the back room and you'll
see them dustin
yeah beautiful that's what we're doing
cool
i just i'd have to say for the record uh
it's my first time trying to rose and it
is extremely [ __ ] good it is very
good
what's the difference between the 19
that josh and i are having which i
thought
you know was exceptional and the 20
that i tasted the other day and we made
a final call on any thoughts
any observations giving people the
preview yeah so not being a salesman
because like i actually because you're
not good at it because i'm not good at
it
nate that's been honestly i think we
would have sold empathy for two times
more
if john was good at selling i think you
sell
sell john's salesmanship uh too long
hey who's better sales you or john
i think i think we have different sales
sales uh this is not political correct
hour with josh weissman this is
answer the questions with garyvee i
think john's better
john's a better salesman who's a better
salesman
ron and you versus me you
how about me versus you john and four
other people
like tyler drock i mean i don't like to
give gary credit that often
i know by the way i know nate nate tell
him can you two tell everybody who's
watching right now how you both went
from
interns to my partner and now
millionaires tell them how you're
millionaires now guys
i'll finish my statement to but i'll say
i usually
don't like to give gary that much credit
but i will say gary's the best salesman
that i've ever seen in my life
by building brand and bringing value
right so you don't have to be a sales
person which is the best
and by listening and kind of and hearing
what people are saying and then
selling what they want because we
haven't providing i prefer
providing gary's the best part by the
way that's how we came up
that's why i think empathy was born like
people want really great wine
john you know this we talked a lot about
this people get hoes at 12 to 15
a bottle people
get get caught when they find 40 wine
because they're like [ __ ] now i can't
drink the 12
wine right like you're stuck and who the
hell can [ __ ] buy 40
wine every night unless you're rich like
john now is and so to me
that's where this 20 ambition and now
that you guys have discounted it for
this event
i'm really pumped about it like i think
the subscription is a real big win
right on yeah i also think uh
not to make this very meta but i feel
like people aren't good at selling wine
because they're not empathetic we
shipped to colorado
oh yeah yes nate do you have more shout
outs i agree on the empathetic part
uh i'm sending out these links to the
two case buyers but um
i feel like you're gonna get more case
buyers because people want to come on
video jerry lynn just bought and james
house just bought to some do they buy
cases or they three bottles
subscriptions
three bottle subscriptions right josh
people love you you're getting a lot of
love in the
comment section what are you cooking
while nate's sending those links
and john's gonna explain to us the lack
of empathy and sales in a few minutes
which
i can't wait to clip that and see it on
his instagram go ahead josh
so okay you know one of the funny things
is i was thinking about as soon as nick
hit me up about this off
i immediately thought back to when you
went on like i forget what it was that
you went on you went on some talk show
and you were like eating literally
eating dirt called no bread
yes yes yes and i thought okay so weird
weird uh pairings with wine and one of
my favorite things to pair with
you know with a rose is indian food
because it's like spicy it's spicy
there's like so many rich flavors
and a nice sort of fruity bouncer jose
really nicely
i'm sorry to interrupt i'm super pissed
john that we didn't sell josh this
because you i literally am tasting this
as josh is talking this is the white
and i'm saying to myself holy [ __ ] i
have some spicy food coming for dinner
and i'm gonna [ __ ] rock
this white josh this white's even made
more for ty
and kind of foe and like i believe it i
have one i'll go pop one right now and
eat it with this
right nice yeah when i finish this one
i'm gonna pop it so what do you mean
basically it so it is indian inspired
but i also wanted there to be a little
bit of a weird quality to it and by
weird i mean
when you think of wine you think of
something classy you know like you've
got your caviar and cucumbers like gary
likes to eat on the side
uh i know and this is a little bit more
sort of juvenile but there's also
something classy about it so it's
it's chicken tikka masala it's made with
a bunch of really nice spices that i
made completely from scratch
uh i also got the cream myself from a
local
uh a local farm so it's like really
really good stuff
but it's within the confines of a case
of taco
so it's like a taco but a quesadilla so
i'm grilling it right now so like melty
cheese
sounds so good you could see i just got
some color i'm about to flip it
dude i'm telling you this is this is
something makes the eyes
roll into the back of the head once it's
done
nate can you tell everybody how much you
love me because i forced you to get into
sports cards he's done extremely well
and how much john has missed the boat
and could have changed his life
those are those are both true gary i
mean gary was talking about sport cards
probably 15 months ago and i doubt
three years i started listening 15
months ago uh
and then i started um
my strategy was not great off the bat i
just bought cards of players that i
liked
poker is a good player but devon booker
isn't good and this white wine is so
good
but it's been awesome i mean the
community and i'm gonna grab it in the
sports card world has been um pretty
cool to see that growth over the past 12
months
nate any more shout outs and did you
send the emails to those two people
nothing those two people said justin as
soon as you've got people no matter what
we're in right now
i want them in here if they come in oh
yeah we got one more
one more uh case purchaser xbox plot
max is gonna get in here proper
you're just joining us we are drinking
wine i am having
the 2019 red which will be if you order
right now on garyvee.com which you'll go
to empathy wines page you'll see three
levels of subscription
if you order now the red will be the
first one right john
that's right yeah it'll come immediately
can you tell people what the 411 is on
this
so this is uh zinfandel and people yeah
people want to know the blends on the
white the road
and the rose and by the way when they
order there they're getting a
subscription so three bottles of red
three bottles of white three
actually it's gonna go red rose white
for everybody buys tonight
on the discount at empathy wines you
know
uh subscription page nice poor there
josh
and that's at garyvee.com which will
redirect you so it's an easy url to
remember
go ahead john um so it's a it's a blend
of
primarily four grapes zinfandel syrah
teacher on cabernet um the irony is when
we were blending the wine
we were actually using the printer as
our biggest inspiration and like good
point
so we did the tasting with like i think
we had 20 red wines lined up
with the top ones from napa valley a
bunch of different red blends
and obviously the one that we had the
most inspiration in was the prisoner
fast forward about a you know a year
after we blended that wine and
sure enough we joined the constellation
brands family which owns the prisoner
so that innovation is amazing um and not
to say that this wine isn't a
carbon copy of the prisoner but this
one's way better than a prisoner is that
gonna get me in trouble with
that no but you know it's funny eye of
the beholder right
one of the things i'm getting very into
as i think both of you if
anybody who's following me on social
media last 48 hours something i've been
studying for about six months
is nfts non-fungible tokens right
art on the blockchain and so i'm getting
very deep into art and
in theory it's just digital and what's
been really fascinating is
it's truly in the eye of the beholder oh
we have somebody here
we have a guest who we have to say thank
you to name is matt
dustin what are you doing here matt's
page is weird could you triple confirm
that matt was in good shape
you ruined the production of our show
best it's okay i can save this one
this cheese pull guys it's gonna be fine
look how big
josh's knife is it's a [ __ ] machete
i got a bigger one if you want to see it
yes i'd like to see you guys
wait look at this this is this is the
savior of the show right here is the uh
the classic one and only
look at that well my stomach just turned
i'm so
into it i want you to know that uh i
i was shooting my cookbook a week ago
and
the cheese pull was is always the most
stressful part and
my director of photography is always
like yeah the worst time to be around
josh is anytime he has to do a cheese
pull
you have one shot right let's say hello
to matt and i also see
uh moshe the concierge 204 a
204 a case but because you're getting
but
it's a subscription the url down below
you get three bottles
three times six bottles three times or a
case
three times but we only bill you
this was a big decision our early like
when we started this company when do we
bill
and we wanted to i wanted a bill all up
front
but nate's a much better man than me and
he's like let's build when they actually
get the wine so you get billed right
away 204 for a case of red that gets
sent to you
this used to be 240 but we're doing a
discount for this show tonight
so it's less than 20 bottle and then you
get billed again when the rose and the
white are ready matt thank you so much
for ordering a subscription uh to our
lovely humble wine project
how are you thank you gary this is
actually about my eighth time
ordering a case of wine you might not
remember this
i i one i don't even drink wine but uh
we you did the barter challenge two
years ago
and uh nate and i worked out a deal
where i trade i remember
for agent 2020 i remember matt i
remember and here's what
what did you what did you do with all
the ones yep he took a picture
uh i i gave it out to customers who
bought rvs so
so here's the best part gary um i had
you as my profile picture for the last
two years
agent 2021 i had 1600 subscribers
and i worked hand-in-hand with lindsay
blaum and she still keeps in contact
with me today
and today i just changed my profile
picture to this
let's go into two years because i hit
100 000 subscribers
good for you brother congratulations
matt yeah man
thank you thank you so that's why you
know i just want support
and um i just want to thank you
and i can't wait for your book to come
out either uh
matt shh because i thought that you know
i'm being very coy about this one but
i'm telling you right now
it's going to be the one i'm so pumped
with what's going on with this book
i'm really proud of it and we're only 30
of the way done
but my team and my maturity of where i
am in my career i think i'm putting some
of my best work on paper
so thank you for saying that hopefully
i'm trying to get it done before the end
of the year so
thank you in good health when you hand
out the wine instead of consuming it
because i know you don't drink it and
thank you for being on with us brother
thanks man have a good one thanks nate
now it's good seeing you
nate any more invoices coming in for you
yeah
um got nancy solorio
um let's see the club people ryan adams
bought a club
uh rodolfo bought a club rodolfo espino
uh alan chris
christiani bought one so i'm gonna send
out a link to those folks right now
thank you i just want to take a five
second break to say thank you to all of
you
you know a lot of you dm me and email me
and say what can i do for you
if you don't drink wine please don't
order this if you don't drink wine but
happy to give gifts to clients or
employees then please order it and if
you drink wine it would mean the world
to me if you ordered a subscription on
garyvee.com
and got a three six or 12 bottle
subscription empathy we think the wines
are remarkable for 20 bucks
really my ambition has always been 40
wine for 20 bucks
for the boys here who are now really
bosses create a discount tonight
which uh you'll see on the page which
takes it below 20 bucks
and the case gets delivered for free so
like did some cool stuff tonight for
this
uh little get together we brought one of
my favorite buddies josh weissman who
have
enjoyed watching from afar build an
incredible community around the food
world i see him drinking our white right
now and i saw his reaction
and thank you so much to everybody
it's so good um
so this red especially has my attention
troutman
um because i'm i'm very passionate about
reds that you can drink by yourself with
cheese
but also will stack up to steak or b for
very complicated pasta dishes
thoughts on the
way we thought the way the grapes came
in on the 19 to give everybody a little
bit behind the scenes
yeah 19 so in the press and funny
people who like really tracked it you
know living out in california like
19 you would think would would have been
a tough vintage just because the
wildfires hit a lot of parts of northern
california
but the actual fruit that was harvested
was i
i think really really really good well
it was on its way to being like
super legit until the virus right yeah
yeah yeah it would have been like an
all-time vintage
um and then really what it just did was
made people have to be that much more
diligent and like what they actually
i actually argued with a friend the
other day that the nineteens are gonna
be super steels
because people were scared to have any
smoke taint
the vintage was epic i think that most
wine makers and wineries because they
worry about their reputation
were even more conservative and you
almost got a creme de la creme that'll
crem
wine i would actually argue that 2019 is
going to end up being a buyer's
paradise yeah yeah and a lot of people
like
the reviews are just coming in now and
take what you will from the critics but
like
on the whole everybody's really praising
it and saying it's really good which i
think surprised a lot of people
um but i think ours to your point around
like
a wine that's really flexible and can be
drunk on like a ton of different
occasions
i think that's why i love it so much
people who really know wine and like
are kind of serious about it taste our
wine and they're really impressed and
then people who don't even think they
like red wine tasted and they're
also have their mind blown i think a lot
of the time which is always fun so
i'm gonna ask josh a food and wine
question but nate john i want you guys
to go off mute
i want to open up you guys can both see
the questions in the comments tab right
yeah there's a lot of people asking
questions about
logistics which will be nate's category
and
wine questions i want to open this up
for people to ask wine questions will be
john's category
literally talk over me and josh right
now because i love chaos and so that's
what i'm looking for here a little chaos
hour
so josh while these boys are answering
all these questions as they stream in
your favorite food and wine pairing and
guys i want you to
correlate yeah coralie yes it's the same
red wine in the 12-pack
josh the number one favorite
right now honestly anything with cheese
but
uh honestly well i was originally gonna
do a grilled cheese for the record
because my favorite pairing
is a grilled cheese and a rose i don't
know why
it just goes well together i really
enjoy it and i don't have to
you know you don't need a lot to make it
happen normally if you have a bottle of
rose or any bottle of wine that's
comparable and some cheese and some
bread
you can have a great wine pairing that's
you know pretty enjoyable
so that's that's my personal favorite
you can ship it again
yeah brock we can ship to wisconsin so
you're you're grilled cheese and rose
grilled cheese and rose or oral white
wine this also by the way as your note
you noted that this white wine goes
really
would go really well with this you were
right it does both of these honestly
pair really well with it
john troutman the vineyards the grapes
are from max j's asking
give us a little give a little story
about the farmers yep
so the 19 comes from mostly two growers
although there's three
all together so one is clay shannon
which there's actually a wall time
episode
all-time video you can't ship to ohio
anymore sadly
no ohio yep good there's a there's an
all-time
video interview of of gary and clay
shannon which i'll actually try to find
and drop into the comments section for
people to watch after this
um clay is a great guy um he
i think like gary you talk about the
analogy of like
buying malibu beachfront property before
people realize it's value you know 50 60
70 years ago
i think clay did that for lake county
100
he just recognized that like napa valley
fruit was getting way too expensive and
as a result you know consumers had to
pay too much
um and meanwhile just a little bit north
he bought up a tunnel in marty county
and is making
some incredible wine he's a big big
portion of the red blend there
i'm sorry to interrupt you john uh
everybody's destroying oh
whoa what's good bro what's going on
thank you so much give me one second
rodolfo for everybody's just joining
the way rodolfo just got in if you go to
garyvee.com
ewine and order the 1k subscription to
concierge
uh nate is looking out for the receipts
and then emailing you this url so you
can join us
you're drinking it let's go i've drank
it
what's good
us about yourself and what question can
i answer for you
wow this is uh this is amazing uh so
one of the things i have to say is you
know how you always talk about like
being the toll booth
you know gary is kind of the toll booth
for other communities around him
so like you're kind of the hub of this
spoke
and i follow like a lot of your uh a lot
of your people um
and just the community that they
surround themselves with and the
positivity around that
is really really nice you know just
saying that yeah absolutely after you're
talking about the d-rocks and the claws
and the others of the world
oh yeah i've been on drawing with zayn a
few times with my kids
i'm at work or else it would be really
really loud in here
i love it thank you so much what are you
up to anything i can answer for you
you know um
so i guess two questions so one one was
based on the twitter post that you had
about um the blockchain being able to
provide
a unique um unique product basically
whatever it is right so it could be art
could be music
even gaming you know people on minecraft
can create and sell
items that are unique um how do you
advise other people to get into that
either as an investor
or maybe as a creator by doing homework
on youtube and google like understanding
what nft stands for
non-fungible tokens how it works getting
a coin base getting a meta mask
knowing what bitsky is like homework
homework homework homework
knowing what crypto punks are knowing
what hash masks are
knowing like education and you know i
rag on not ragon i have a problem
with college for a certain group of
humans on earth i don't think it's a
one-size-fits-all the way society did
for 40 years but my greatest belief is
education
right and so getting educated
and so rodolfo i think it's really going
down the rabbit hole of nft
what does nft mean like doing what i've
done the last six months
i've done tens and tens and tens of
hours
of consuming information so i understand
what's so rare in nba top shot and
you know all these things mean you know
the flamingo project like
you got to get educated and so i think
there's something going on
in a real way on uh on blockchain and i
think
i'm happy for the artists and the
creators because they're gonna be able
to keep the economics and
there's a lot to be explored and i think
a lot of people are going to struggle
with understanding it
the way people struggled with
understanding the internet in 1994-567
and i highly recommend a lot of people
there's a lot of people at 30 40 50
years old
now 20 20 30 40 years old
who make fun of their parents for not
understanding the internet
and they're completely lost on
blockchain and it's because they're not
willing to do
what they did as kids which is get
educated
and so that's my answer on nft i'm very
very very bullish on it
the digitalization what's a clubhouse
invite going for
120 bucks on ebay that's an invite to a
platform
that is virtual like vr is brewing
what's a what do you think a blue check
on instagram is worth to some people
right now
when people like gary why are you buying
two thousand dollar
digital art i'm like i don't know why
would you
why do you spend 5 000 hours of your
life dwelling that you don't have a blue
check on instagram
like you know so these are things that
why do you spend eight thousand dollars
on a belt
that has a gucci logo on it humans
communicate and the digital world is the
digital world now
the end why did matt show a little
plaque right now 100
000 subscribers why did josh know
exactly what that plaque melt
because the digital world is the world
period and the story
so i would get educated on nft for real
robelto for real
yeah no 100 percent started this weekend
i mean you know crypto is
being able to store your assets without
borders
but real quick there will be incredible
amounts of money lost
sure not just me yeah so education
education education
all right i got to leave in a little bit
so i'm going to kick you off but thank
you for the support enjoy the wines love
you man
love you more yes charles i think you
got it with marvlin ufc
thomas what's good bro hey how's it
going guys real good thank you so much
for the support
yeah man um my business partner we on a
bar that's currently
closed because of covid but we own a
wine bar in albuquerque new mexico
that's what's up brother and uh yeah
last time i drank with him we drank that
empathy rose that was amazing
thank you man how are you um i'm doing
well just uh
i've always been brick and mortar never
digital picked up my first camera six
months ago
starting to make as much content as
possible in both realms
uh love josh i got um he's amazing my
business partner introduced to josh
and then he introduced me to you gary so
yeah just just because this business
card this business partner sounds
amazing
oh yeah he he's all right i mean
well a big shout out to grace johnson
thank you for ordering scott gardner
thank you for ordering
yes dustin do that anybody who's
claiming that they're ordering and also
nate
i want you to look back at the film
anybody here who just claimed that they
ordered
just to get dustin to show them if they
didn't actually order
nate i need you to rewatch this send it
to me so i can publicly shame them
and we can literally blackball their
name for being not nice people
got an eight year on you thomas what uh
anything we can answer for you real
quick before we bounce out of here
um just the transition from
like the physical world to the digital
world
what's the easiest way to get around
that because i know the business world
and it just it's so difficult to
translate because i've always hired so
many people for my social
and stuff like that that doing it myself
and producing my own brand that way it
seems really
first you need to know it cold and then
you can hire somebody so you know what
you're looking for brand by the way nate
allen k is claiming that he just ordered
my 20 cases i need to get confirmation
on that
i don't see a 20 case order yet all
right
allen k we need to figure that out so
going back to our beautiful guest here
i think that um tom i think that
once you know what you're doing it's a
lot easier
for you to figure out how to hire
somebody or keep somebody
you understand i'm a big fan of you
knowing first and then taking it from
there
you know that's how i do all my business
like even if there's a dj playing at my
restaurant i wanted to know
right now
so i don't have any editors nothing like
that i do it all myself but it's a hard
road
but it's a super hard road josh let's
speak to you your road
right now you got 3.5 million you know
followers on on
on your youtube did you josh remind me
did you pop thank you chris for
your case subscription did you pop on
tick tock first josh or youtube first or
how did it go down for you
it was really weird it was well kind of
both i popped on youtube and then i
started my tick tock
well you know how you would you had been
talking about tick tock for a while and
i already
agreed with you but i started it and i
didn't tell anybody
because i was like i want to test this
algorithm out and i just went hard
and i developed a formula for it and it
popped off on its own
organically completely separate from
youtube so they both popped off
separately and then eventually people
finally came together and they're like
wait a minute that's like everyone
let's go from youtube and then it was
like yeah big shout out
okay i got it he did it through the no
bull conference seventh and eighth night
that was that big bold quarter got it
um real pleasure thank you um
let me so tom i think it's just you know
chug along and then you'll know what
you're looking for and then you know
when you hire somebody good
i mean i hire people that are wrong all
the time it's about not dwelling when
you make somebody
um when you pick someone that didn't
work out yeah it's true
the dwelling the the ego and the lack of
humility in hiring tom
is what hurts people from scaling uh
yeah i i just need to know first it's
like
well that you gotta yeah that you gotta
put in the work yeah yeah the work and
the patience
i just wanted to know if there's any
tips and stuff the tips are [ __ ] put
in the work
it's kind of like push-ups here's the
tip do push-ups
do 10 a day once you get better here and
do 15 once you do better you'll be doing
100 no problem nate i don't know if
you're seeing this snape but it's
starting
bicep peaks let's get up it's starting
to happen i got some i got some shout
outs for orders
okay go ahead nate i'm sorry thomas
thank you for being on thank you
love you guys love you more cindy thomas
christopher
cozzolino anthony
uh moshi gersht scott gardner chris
jacobson felix goodson
jonathan alfaro grace johnson who you
gave a shout out to before
cat hart joshua robinson tom oh that was
just thomas right there
and now we're caught up it's nice it's
nice
neil gary
what's up what's up i wanted to know i
wanted to know one thing
i want to know note one thing about the
guy before because you had you had said
it's about doing the work et everything
that gary has ever
said like is not only accurate i mean i
i've lived it
i when i i was listening to him in the
car when i was like
you know 17 and like going to the gym
getting my ass kicked
uh and it was basically the only thing i
would say
is if there if there's a secret that
somebody is looking for obviously it
doesn't exist but more specifically you
uncover the secret by actually doing the
[ __ ] action
so you because the secret is your own
individualized experience
100 100 neil how are you brother i like
the black on black dodgers hat my boy
justin turner
who vayner sports represents we signed
yesterday or the day before so we're
excited about that
i i know that and i'm i'm glad uh you
know he stuck around i think he wanted
he wanted to be there and we're really
gonna be uh
it's gonna be an interesting you know
adding you know forever
bauer and my brother aj are friendly so
i i i'm a big bauer fan i think it's a
huge signing for you guys
marisol if you don't like red wine you
can buy the rose or the white as a
one-off too
nice nate neil what's cooking thank you
for this john nate can you thank neil
for the
case subscription that's how he got on i
mean can you guys thank you
i had to get on thank you for the people
are listening okay
um you know i'm an actor producer worked
it on and off
behind the camera born and raised in the
film and tv industry for
years got taken down with parents
getting ill 10 years ago
i'm sorry to hear that uh you know just
crazy when you deal with that you know
ripped sort of like
right the rug right out from under you
you're like back up against the wall
i had real estate in our family that
went underwater
it was like hey you know you had to
hustle you had to grind
and gary i found you about a few years
ago and you and i are around the same
age
and i like watched you sort of grow
through those years
like what you were doing and paying
attention to what you were doing
and it probably was about a year ago
where i just was like
so on a regular basis i'm like gary
thinks
like very i love the way he thinks i
like how forward-minded
he is and i can't tell you how many
things when i was low
down low i get up against the wall
you know just having the hardest time
your advice and your wisdom and just
knowing from experience speaks to me
because my mind works in that way
like where things are going and i had to
like i had to buy
the subscription not only to be like hey
i gotta thank you
personally but also to give back
you dropped so much stuff for free
and so many people like that
watch you when you talk about it all the
time the more value that you can drop
the more stuff that you can help people
with like
then find a way to give back and so for
me it's giving back to you and at the
same time i get some great wine
yes thank you so much and then at the
same time i was in
the reason why and everybody in this
room or everybody following him right
now the reason why i'm on clubhouse
because i'm coming from a creator
standpoint is because of garyvee
he mentioned it twice and i was like
what the [ __ ] is club
and i was like i got a and a friend of
mine invited me
like a month and i was i don't need
another like social media
yeah you know and i'm like inviting all
my network like really like
people that are doing really well in all
different industries and they're like eh
i'm like okay they'll get to it
but anyways i was in the room i missed
you by a tab with paulo the other day
and dan fleischman in the sports cards
room
and i was like oh man i miss gary but
i'm doing some cool stuff so josh
like you know i'm collaborating with
some different people find me on
clubhouse i got some cool stuff coming
through
you can fall into some deals there like
any of you guys
i love new york get get deep on nft
oh no i'm dude i just was in the nft's
tips the other day
and eric uh i think i think
i think people that are naturally
creative and you being in the hollywood
land
yeah are gonna are gonna find a lot of
happiness in nft life
yeah my my brother's a visual artist
also does different stuff and we have
visual artist friends as well
and i literally like stumbled upon it a
couple weeks ago
because i'm in the crypto space too and
a little bit like from investment
like you know stuff and i literally was
like
i gotta like wrap my head around the nft
space
i mean it's spend more time on it so let
me ask you one question too sure
what do you think and and you know
because i know you got other people to
go to
what do you think top shot and whenever
the nfl
and whenever the other sort of you know
the leagues get into the nft space what
do you think topshop does
to like the current panini tops like all
the time
i think they coexist yeah let me give
you an example back to the blue check
i think the blue check on instagram is
cool and i think the vip table
at the hottest club in vegas that
weekend is cool right
people are desperate with or
people are neil the world is desperate
for ore
and i know it's and that has been my
life
the world everybody thinks the world is
restricted
and i know the world is abundant both
nft art
and this art by elise barton who worked
for me for a long time
will both coexist yeah for at least as
long as most of us live
do i believe if i looked out 80 years
that people could live in pods
like that [ __ ] ready player one [ __ ]
yeah i i you could sell me on that 80
years out
but for the [ __ ] that are watching
right now neil everybody wants it to be
ore
or it's going to be the regular cards or
nft it's going to be
real real estate or virtual no no and
and fall in love with [ __ ] and
right now i agree i i'm with you i i'm
scared you know i was curious on that um
but man thank you thank you thank you
yours means a lot to me
thank you all right keep doing what
you're doing i will
and uh and you guys find me you know on
clubhouse you know
i'm doing doing some cool stuff
um nate maybe you can do some final
shout outs because i gotta run
yeah we got a uh josh ordonez who was a
former former our first intern
i know josh good to see josh um
purchased
thank you josh uh brock mccain
carolyn jones danielle kilcullen
probably butchered that last name but um
yep good oh gosh
let's go baby nice hat dude
you gave it to me thank you i'm aware
how are you
i'm awesome how are you it's great to
see you what's up josh you too
what's up guys hello thank you you too
by the way
john is an excellent salesman he just
sold me right now let's go
although i don't have any empathy like
the only god you got some josh
i love it good for you yeah that's cool
have you been
i've been i've been great gary i've been
awesome how are you
i'm well you look well thank you thank
you
i'm proud of you guys last time i saw
josh he looks better than you the last
time i saw him
you trout on the other hand you've
gotten a little bit
your hairs go up further down trust me
i'm thinking about getting an afro
implant
you should do josh i'm thinking about
getting an implant like your hair
just because i wanna like i wanna i
wanna i wanna
like i want long ass hair and just do
wild
i mean in the next that's the only
reason gary likes me
yeah listen i'm making it a core
decision i'm either going completely
i'm gonna shave and go bald or or
more likely i'm going to get josh's hair
implant
just so i can do some like wrestling
[ __ ]
what are your thoughts on that trout
would you vote for bald because i'm into
the implanting lebron
brady you know [ __ ] erlacker like i
think
men's implant hair is like real now
i think you should go for it although i
will say
you looked far better today
12 years ago
you're you're in incredible shape
compared to where you were yes dude i'm
like putting [ __ ] together like i don't
think you guys understand what's
actually going on
like i put on like 12 pounds of muscle
during cover josh
wow let's go
like eight to ten that's amazing i will
destroy you
in most chess exercises at this point
most
like you look better than this the funny
picture
the first time i've been wait so you can
implant hair is that a thing
have you seen what lebron and tom brady
did
josh has never had to look that up yeah
yeah josh is [ __ ] amazing
yeah implant here is like like one of my
hot takes is that
we're in 2021 in 20 josh in 2030
it will become extremely normalized
for men's hair transplants and most guys
not all some people prefer like half and
half but like
i think you will be blown away by how
many people go
men's implants like hair like like it's
funny like
i'm like very you nate john you know
this about me i can go very extreme
like i'm like i like the grays i'll go
ball but then i'm like
no i'm gonna [ __ ] go like green like
like josh's hair the green i can i run
very hot
on this but yeah dude it's like i think
we're
i think we're dangerously close to it
being normalized and non-taboo
like on the presbyters
which i think is great for trout and
nate i think
it's a
dude i'm gonna actually like actually
ask for you to cut your hair so that
could be what's implanted into my head
josh what have you been what's going on
which one john ordonias yeah which one
yeah
yeah so i i kind of just have like my
own marketing agency now it's pretty
cool
uh yeah yeah like i kind of had like one
client
and then picked up two clients and then
um
like i now like broker like brand deals
for uh some talent
um a lot of like basically like a lot of
people like
they see that work with brands and so
they hit me up and they're like hey like
you know if any projects come in like
hit me up uh let me know and you get a
percentage
so um yeah i mean it's been really cool
because um
i get to do multiple things at once and
uh
yeah like it's everything can be done
like at home it's awesome
i'm so proud of you man keep pushing hey
marcus i appreciate that comment
what did marcus get for you all right
josh ordonez great to see you we love
you bro thank you for the support
weissman great to see you i'm heading
out this is my uh
last right hook it would mean the world
to me um garyvee.com
e wine uh that will send you to
a landing page at empathy wines the
brand that us
three very handsome gentlemen on this
call all of which are destined for hair
implants
created and we would really really
appreciate
um any subscriptions either the 3
6 or 12 bottle and
we really think we made an incredible 20
wine which ironically
because the boys here discounted for
this event is even less than that
free shipping on the case order stuff
pretty excited about it
wines are epic john nate thank you i
love you like brothers as you know
and thank you for everybody dustin
please come on here so i can thank you
for being on the ones and twos once
again extremely
extremely um capable
dustin i also want to talk to you about
nfts
yeah i mean i heard you mention it but i
didn't know it was a
creator related so now oh it's i'm like
intrigued
yeah you're gonna love it you're too
creative for this [ __ ] like
um uh big shout out to drock who's
dustin's
agent and manager
anna bellinger josh krebs isaiah
mitchell
thank you thank you thank you i'm just
super thankful for everybody who
supported this project
and you know here's what's cool final
parting shot
these are remarkably good 20 lines and
like if you drink wine
and you're ordering right now from
drizzly or ralph's or
totalwine or y.com or anything else even
wine tax for that matter
i think you should order a subscription
of wine to empathy wines
and i think you should do it today
because the discount is going to go away
so garyvee.com ewine it would mean a lot
a lot to nate
first and foremost john second third
dustin and then b4
if you could subscribe to the
subscription that is the url to our
subscription page
we appreciate you hanging out tonight i
hope you enjoyed i hope you got some
laughs in with the hearing
implants we got intrigued by nfts
um and and most of all i just hope you
were entertained and
got to escape real life for a little bit
and i hope you have a wonderful night
please hit me up on twitter garyvee
and let me know how you enjoyed this
session uh and we will see you soon take
care everyone
good night thanks everybody